from the most dangerous areas around
hakeev there is an almost constant
exodus
people fleeing homes they don't know if
they will ever see again
[Music]
among those who have been helping with
evacuations here oleg koval and his wife
julia
she was very brave at the start of the
war says oleg prior to the invasion she
didn't have the opportunity to show it
but as soon as the war started her
bravery was clear
but then they drove once again through
heavily shelled streets like this in the
suburb of saltivca
but this time it would end in tragedy
this is oleg's video of the aftermath of
a rocket attack on a building from which
they were evacuating more people
julia was buried in the rubble he had to
dig her out with his own hands two days
after the explosion
met oleg at her graveside the teddy
bears are gifts he promised to buy her
just before she died
he told us more about the struggle to
recover his wife's body
she is dividing
yes it was two days before we could get
her out because there was constant
shelling and nobody wanted to go there
but together with one brave man we did
it we got her and took her to the morgue
and identified her and so on
nobody is being buried anymore
but i'm lucky i have friends and now
she's able to lay here
i ask him what he thinks of the people
who invaded his country
i just wish that everything russian
would die on the borders of ukraine and
so if you could call it culture it would
not spread anymore and would not infect
this planet with their wildness and
weakness of character i don't see
anything strong about them and they
don't know what true kindness is
he says he will soon start evacuating
people again
because if my wife laid down her life
for the sake of other people in this
pointless war then i have nothing else
to do except continue doing what she
started
one more story of appalling loss in a
city whose tragedy is far from over
mark austin sky news
hakiv